well firstly i would urge you not to
read tabloids hopefully one day that
they come with a warning label like
cigarettes do like this is toxic for
your mental health meghan markle's
speaking out against tabloid culture and
sharing her reaction to tuesday's
important court ruling you know in terms
of this
the appeal i won the case megan took
part in the new york times deal book
summit a conversation focused on
bridging the gap in the workplace for
women and so i've been gone from the u.s
for a really long time and to come back
and now be a mother of two
and to see that the u.s is one of only
six countries in the entire world that
doesn't offer any form of national paid
leave
just didn't make sense discussion later
turned to how the duchess of sussex is
portrayed in the media leading to this
candid comment about tabloid journalism
i've read great things about you as a
boss and if you read the tabloids you
can read all sorts of crazy things about
it being a boss well first i would urge
you not to read tabloids
because i don't think that's healthy for
anyone hopefully one day they come with
a warning label like cigarettes do like
this is toxic for your mental health i
mean let's not forget the sussex said
they wanted to leave the uk to avoid the
intrusion of the british media megan
heads up her and husband prince harry's
charity the archwell foundation
according to the duchess she and her
husband always come back to the golden
rule we're just doing it the same way
that
that we would want if we were employees
of it right so to treat people the way
you want to be treated that is always
how i've moved my husband has always
said with great privilege comes great
responsibility and a responsibility
megan said that extends to their work in
politics i think this is one of those
issues that is not
red or blue we can all agree that people
need support megan has personally
reached out to senators and companies
advocating for paid family leave for all
americans and i think if this entire
country if you know if we valued
american families in that way as we
should
it sets us up for economic growth and
success but it also just really allows
people to have that very sacred time as
a family before anyone thinks the royal
couple might become more political megan
set the record straight i don't see this
as a political issue frankly
look there's certainly a precedent
amongst my husband's family and the
royal family of not having any
involvement in politics but i think this
is i mean paid leave from my standpoint
is just a humanitarian issue megan also
reacted to the latest development in her
court battle with the mail on sunday a
press outlet that published a private
letter she sent to her father thomas
markle in 2018. yeah well you know in
terms of this
the appeal i won the case and this issue
frankly has been going on
when i had no children at all so it's an
arduous process earlier this year a high
court judge in london ruled that
associated newspaper limited the british
tabloid's parent company invaded megan's
privacy she'd been
through a high court case against the
mail on sunday she won that privacy
court case so a big victory for megan
but on tuesday the publisher launched an
official challenge against that verdict
at the uk's court of appeal as for what
comes next in the court saga megan said
she will continue following her moral
compass but again it's just me standing
up for what's right which i think is
important across the board across the
board be it in this case or in the other
things we've been talking about today at
a certain point no matter how difficult
it is you know the difference between
right and wrong you must stand up for
what's right and that's what i'm doing
[Music]
you